on the mound is
zach davies for the san diego padres 27
year old making his third start
swinging a miss comes back to strikeout
calhoun on a pitch should appear to be
out of the zone first strike out of the
night
for jack davies 1-1 to starling martay
hit on the ground to short tatis has got
it
his throw is good and the first inning
is over
luke weaver on the mound about to get
his second start against the padres this
year
here's fernando tatissa lead it off
diamondbacks won an order against davies
in the first
drives this one to deep left center
field back goes martay
what a start for the padres fernando
tati's junior goes deep with one swing
of the bat the padres take a one-nothing
lead
zach davies has got himself a lead to
work with
swinging a miss and walker strikes out
second strikeout for zach davies
in the air to shallow left almante
coming in
he'll get there to make the catch
they've really stumbled onto something
with rookie jay cronin wearing
318 two doubles two triples a home run
he's an excellent defensive player
put some wood to that high fly ball to
deep right field
ball going his kid is legit
the boys have a two-nothing lead over
the diamondbacks
[Applause]
hits one toward the corner call calhoun
with a running grab
and that will retire the side davies has
not allowed a baserunner yet he's got a
two-nothing lead in the third
and a swing and a miss off-balance he
strikes out third k for davies
swing and a miss and he battles back to
strikeout jake lamb
nicely done two-two swinging amaze got
him with a change up down and three
straight strikeouts on that pitch for
zach davies
strikes out the side in the third five
k's through three
top of the order here second time
through now against zach davies
center field and grisham started back
now coming in full board grisham will
dive and make the catch in center
trent grisham initially fooled on that
recovers with great speed
and makes a great diving catch for the
first out of the fourth inning
lined into right field machado's got it
the throw gonna be close and it's in
time
nice play now the pitch and a hard hit
liner to left almante though was
positioned perfectly just a few steps
over towards the line
he makes the catch and the inning is
over
still looking for their first base
runner 12 up 12 down right now
swing and a miss and walker strikes out
strikeout number six for zach davies
opens up the fifth inning
3-2 eduardo gets it into right center
field meyers over to cut it off escobar
will have a long
single with one out and the d-backs have
their first base runner tonight
[Applause]
peralta sends one out to left center
field escobar will stop at second base
a couple of one ounce singles here
in the air shallow left out goes tatis
back pedaling to catch out number three
edward olivares is pinch hitting here
235 no homer has two runs batted in ole
varus drives one to deep right field
calhoun going back at the wall the
ball's gone
a pitch hit home run for olivares first
major league home run for
olivares padres leading three nothing on
three
solo home runs there's a shot
into center and marty on the run sprints
to right center
and makes a catch takes an extra base
hit and a runaway for the padres
retiring grisham to end the fifth inning
taylor clark is going to come into this
game for
arizona taylor clark impressive comes
out
to strike out machado to start the sixth
inning
taylor clark two batters two strikeouts
and two down in the sixth
taylor clark showing some outstanding
command tonight
ground ball hit to short ahmed's got it
and he throws cronenworth out and that's
a one-two three
now enter left-hander drew pomeranz his
seventh game
five in the third eight strikeouts who
strikes him out again as he got him for
the fifth time of his career
and six played appearances and walker
strikes out for the third time tonight
on the ground but right to profar it's
second base
two down in the seventh inning with two
outs and a runner at first we'll deal
with the pensioner and andy young
and now strikes out to end the top of
the seventh inning
emilio pagan into his sixth game
end of the shift it's machado from short
right with a good throw and plenty of
time to get jake lamb
it's a high fly ball to left field
olivares back there i'll make the catch
for out number two
kattel takes on the inside corner strike
three call that was the cutter that was
a one two three
eighth inning for emilio pagan and they
hand the baseball off to the closer
kirby yates
strike three call kirby yates has out
number one of the ninth inning
two down on the ninth inning gonna bring
up eduardo escobar
lined and cut by cronenworth and the
padres win
a shutout tonight for the san diego
padres in game one of the three game
weekend series against the diamondbacks